jeff parfois les artistes singulièrement
les acteurs ont du mal avec la
popularité c'est une forme de pression
aussi la popularité comment est ce que
mes demandes aux vives et non seulement
cette popularité mais je reprends le mot
de bernard cette unanimité
comme vous dites en fait je connais pas
mal d'artistes et salle au bout de cinq
minutes les photos les selfs y aura jean
paul c'est ce que disait bernard thaler
c'est quelqu'un qui était d'humeur
constante ce qui est très rare dans ce
milieu dans ce métier je n'ai jamais vu
en quinze ans refuser une photo un
autographe alors d'un côté misé qu'est
ce que tu me fasses avec ma jambe je
veux pas courir mais il n'y avait pas
que ça je sais mais il avait l'amour du
public l'amour des gens c'était quelque
chose de sincère j'ai une anecdote
rentrant soir à l'hôtel martinez à
cannes c'est assez tard il pleuvait
c'est fatiguant n'avait pas ces trois
journées c'était du style minuit et on
arrive tout au fond de l'hôtel est un
gars qui arrive en courant monsieur
bellemans vous ai vu passer on fête
l'anniversaire nous on fera dans un
restaurant est ce que pouvaient venir le
site et bon anniversaire quel l'acteur
serait ressorti à 8 sous la pluie malgré
son handicap il rentre dans le
restaurant la salle l'acclament il fait
bon anniversaire
ça c'est unique
karim d'ailleurs karim maintenant que je
vous vois là depuis si je trouve que
j'avais vraiment une gueule une
gueule pas seulement deux films
marseille et je pense qu'ils pourraient
faire c'est pas trop tard ils pouvaient
faire carrière qu'est ce que ça
représentait bel pour vous des remakes
de borsalino
non moi je me disais en regardant toutes
les images qui défilaient derrière toi
il a toujours le sourire
c'est vachement rats que l'être humain
sourit toujours et en permanence il a la
banane et moi l'art ti l'artiste est
l'acteur le comédien évidemment fabuleux
un professionnel hors pair un type qui a
dû travailler énormément pour atteindre
le niveau qui est le sien on croit
toujours que c'est facile une fois connu
une icône mais la réalité surtout lui
parce qu'il donne une impression de
facilité au départ il a ému beaucoup
d'obstacles trois fois donc avant de
rendre conservatoire en libye et jamais
turin les plus belles femmes dans tes
bras il les a eus seul andres laurent
bonelli carlos sotto mayor et j'en passe
en fait tout ce qu'on avait prédit pour
lui c'est le contraire qui se dira qui
s'est déroulée